[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
hoy vamos a aprender que él se la toma
de acuerdo esa clase en quinto grado era
la clase de ciencias inmediatamente que
el profesor empezó a explicar que es el
átomo me pareció un concepto fascinante
que los átomos no se puedan ver pero que
sean parte de la unidad que compone
todas las cosas a nuestro alrededor me
pareció increíble
me puse a ver las bruscas que estaban de
borrador en el escritorio y mi profesor
notó que probablemente yo estaba
pensando en los átomos inmediatamente me
dijo en esas bruscas no hay uno no hay
dos hay muchísimos átomos realmente no
los podemos ver esa noche yo no podía
dejar de pensar en lo que había
aprendido ese día
este profesor se dedicó a enseñar
ciencias de una forma muy práctica y
haciendo experimentos con el pasar de
los años además yo tuve la ventaja de
que mi mamá y yo disfrutamos muchísimo
resolviendo problemas de matemáticas y
por otro lado mi papá nos inculcaba el
amor por aprender y por hacer preguntas
siempre con el diccionario en la mesa el
diccionario era la herramienta para
contestar todas las preguntas que le
hacíamos a mis papás las mujeres hoy en
día tienen formación profesional incluso
sabemos de muchas profesiones donde las
mujeres están muy bien representadas
pero este no es el caso de las ciencias
como la física o la química las
tecnologías las ingenierías y la
matemática
en abreviado en inglés este tipo de
carrera se les llama stem los países con
mayor número de mujeres graduadas son
países como argelia donde se están
graduando 40 por ciento de mujeres en
estas carreras o los emiratos árabes que
están graduando 35 por ciento de mujeres
en contraste países como bélgica como
finlandia gradúan sólo 20 por ciento de
mujeres en estos campos y estos países
tienen un alto índice de equidad en
promedio en el mundo hoy de 100
graduados en stem 25 somos mujeres esta
información viene de un estudio de 68
países y los datos vienen de la unesco y
el foro económico mundial se concluye en
el estudio que entre más equidad de
género menor es el porcentaje de mujeres
que se gradúan en stem es un fenómeno
paradójico los sociólogos los psicólogos
han estado estudiando esto por décadas y
aún es difícil conocer todas las razones
de esta tendencia
es importante aclarar que en los últimos
años si se ha notado un incremento en el
número de mujeres en las ciencias
sociales y en las ciencias de la salud
ya casi llegando a niveles del 50 por
ciento de representación
la razón de la falta de las mujeres en
stem no parece estar relacionada con
resultados en exámenes de ciencias o de
matemáticas pues en la mayor parte de
los países los niños y las niñas
muestran igual rendimiento de esas
materias imaginémonos sacarla un
estudiante de escuela ella es buena en
matemáticas y pensamos en felipe los
resultados de ambos son muy parecidos
pero carla además es sobresaliente en
castellano a ella le encanta la lectura
y la escritura y le va muy bien en la
escuela felipe le va muy bien en
matemáticas sus resultados en castellano
no son tan buenos
carla entonces crece sintiendo que ella
es mejor en comunicación y felipe mejor
en matemáticas
las empresas públicas de mayor valor en
el mundo hoy y las que generan mayor
riqueza son compañías basadas en alta
tecnología en computación y en finanzas
todas requieren que sus trabajadores
tengan educación profesional en stem o
en negocios y con sólo un 25 por ciento
de mujeres graduándose de estas
profesiones la mayoría de las mujeres no
tienen cómo insertarse en este campo
laboral tan competitivo y tan bien
remunerado además las compañías no son
tan innovadoras como lo podrían ser el
nivel de productos y servicios brindados
por estas compañías no incluyen ideas de
todos los puntos de vista se ha
demostrado que al aumentar el número de
mujeres en las compañías éstas producen
mejores productos y además rendimientos
financieros más altos a principios de
los años 2000 los fabricantes de carros
hicieron cambios en sus grupos de diseño
incrementando el número de mujeres y
gracias a este cambio en los grupos de
diseño se instalaron espejos de
conversación los espejos que se usan a
la parte del espejo retrovisor para
poder ver a los pasajeros del asiento de
atrás se aumentó el tamaño de los
tanques de gasolina para evitar las
paradas frecuentes en las gasolineras
además se diseñó el ajuste de la altura
de los pedales para facilitar el alcance
a las personas de baja estatura y se
enfatizó aún más en la seguridad del
diseño al tener mamás diseñadoras en los
grupos la importancia de producir carlos
más seguros cambió en el año 2025 se
estima que existirán 2 millones de
puestos vacantes en tecnología y eso
sólo es una cifra de eeuu
por ejemplo además la mayoría de los
estudiantes del colegio hoy en eeuu no
saben qué tipo de trabajo hacen los
ingenieros haciendo la tarea de cerrar
la brecha de puestos vacantes aún más
difícil y no solo graduamos un bajo
porcentaje de mujeres además las mujeres
al ingresar al mundo laboral muchas
dejan los trabajos técnicos de lado cabe
preguntarse cuáles son las razones por
las cuales las mujeres dejan de las
profesiones existen existen muchos
estudios y en mi experiencia yo creo que
hay tres razones principales una es el
miedo al fracaso otra los estereotipos
culturales y además la falta de ejemplos
y oportunidades el miedo al fracaso tal
vez empieza en años escolares al empezar
ya tener pánico a las matemáticas pero
además se refleja en actitudes de
perfeccionismo y sobre preparación en
las niñas
se ha concluido en diferentes estudios
que las niñas tienden a dudar más de sus
propias habilidades
y dudan además de los conocimientos
adquiridos cuando se comparan con sus
compañeros de clase
cada vez que yo tomo una decisión
difícil o embarco en alguna aventura que
me genera temor yo primero llamo a mis
amigos llamo a mis familiares y siempre
llamo a mi hermana que no le tiene miedo
a nada pero el ser valiente no significa
no sentir miedo significa más bien
superar temores y para mí el éxito está
en la red de apoyo que yo tengo la
solución que propongo es que seamos
parte de la red de soporte de nuestras
jóvenes pregúntele a su sobrina o a su
prima si sienten miedo al escoger una
profesión ayuden a entender la causa de
cualquier temor si es usted el profesor
de colegio o maestro de escuela promueve
una cultura de autoestima y de confianza
en las destrezas de las niñas procuramos
que nuestras niñas crezcan con deseos de
aprender de entender el medio ambiente
de conocer cómo funcionan las cosas
se decía antes que la necesidad es la
madre de la invención hoy debemos decir
la curiosidad es la madre de la
invención la curiosidad nos lleva a
aprender de las ciencias y nos da las
primeras herramientas para empezar a
entender el mundo que nos rodea
ojalá además invita a las dos siguientes
generaciones a resolver tantísimos
problemas a los cuales no les hemos
encontrado soluciones hoy
yo he sido privilegiada no solo tengo
una familia que me apoya y tuve
profesores de ciencias y matemáticas
excelentes además tuve la dicha de ser
admitida del colegio científico de
cartago en ese ambiente de soporte y de
exigencia académica teníamos una
invitación diaria a experimentar a ser
curiosos aprendemos aprendimos a
discutir aprendimos a investigar sí
claro que nos quemamos las pestañas y
tal vez fue difícil pero disfrutamos
muchísimo esos últimos dos años de
colegio
y sabían ustedes que hoy los colegios
científicos tienen cupos vacantes no
todos los colegios están llenos
enseñamos a las niñas a ser curiosas a
estudiar más allá de lo que los maestros
requieren en la escuela los niños
tienden a ser excelentes lectores qué
tipos de libros les estamos dando
estamos enseñándoles a hacer preguntas
difíciles les enseñamos a buscar sus
propias respuestas y lo más importante
saben las niñas qué pasión tienen tienen
interés en algún tema si ellas sienten
pasión por algún tema les nacerá el amor
por aprender naturalmente el estudio y
la disciplina serán parte del día a día
para ccoo y lola están pensionados esos
libros ya yo creo que no existen
pero piensen cuáles son los modelos o
los ejemplos que siguen las niñas hoy
casi todas quieren ser princesas será
ese el modelo correcto
cuál princesa es ingeniera cuál princesa
se llena de barro para hacer una
carretera cual princesa construyó su
propio carruaje
en los cuentos del hada madrina hace
magia y convierte una calabaza en
carruaje o aparece el príncipe azul que
salva a la princesa si bien las
princesas han cambiado y algunas son
aventureras y otras son guerreras me
parece que hacen falta otros modelos
desde pequeños abramos los horizontes de
las niñas evitemos el uso de modelos y
patrones que no tienen espacio en una
sociedad equitativa preparemos a la
juventud a solucionar los muchos
problemas que enfrentamos haciendo el
uso del conocimiento científico y los
avances tecnológicos sólo así vamos a
resolver los tantos problemas que
tenemos que resolver en el futuro
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah